[Music]
this episode of shots of Oz brought to
you by Toyota
[Music]
so I'm fascinated by the paradoxical
function of art is that great line that
says art is the lie that reveals the
truth this paradoxical nature the fact
that art speaks to a kind of deeper
ecstatic truth that goes beyond
empirical truth goes beyond empirical
reality it scratches the very edges of
our psyche digs deeply into our soul it
appeals to that space of archetype dream
myth metaphor right
it's like Verner Hertzog used to say you
know facts are not the most interesting
thing in the world if facts are the most
interesting thing in the world then go
buy the phone book it's full of facts
what we're interested in is ecstatic
truth which is telling them what
reveals deeper truths than a
journalist's more literal grit in other
words the artist gets us somewhere
beyond and a factual and somehow reveals
truth there's something kind of
beautiful about that idea you know and I
think that's that's the function of art
to communicate with us at that depth and
then thus worth celebrating
[Music]
you